we caught up with Derrick Rose yesterday
and after the show he's got a new book
out and I started the conversation by
asking him why he decided to write this
autobiography uh it all started with me
wanting to get my word out during the
past I felt like I let the media patrol
or dictate everything that was going on
because I really couldn't focus on
really paying attention too much to that
because I was living in the moment and
in the moment I was just going through a
lot figuring out who I was as a person
I had my son at the time and I was just
figuring out a lot of things I'm just
trying to grow up and now that I have
time to reflect back on on it it just
showed that execute the right way I had
a lot of ups and downs but to get to 12
years and to get to my twelfth year and
having my injury my third year it showed
I did something right toughest thing to
write about was one everything
everything I'm very I'm a very secretive
person but I just wanted to give our
part so I'll know if you know but I put
out a documentary and I wanted to put
the book with the documentary like as
like a package but it didn't work out
that way and I put them out separately
and I just wanted to get the people with
my fans that really loved me a chance to
see why they're drawn to me like all my
fans and I run into people like they
they love me they vibe with me in a
certain way but I never opened up to
people and it always came from just a
feel of feeling like that they get that
they got from me that they couldn't
relate to and I just wanted to give them
a little bit more and Shawn just another
side of them how did how you grew up
form your personality I think it for my
personality a lot I think that I grew up
kind of
different than your average athlete or
average person like I grew up in the
impoverished area and along the way I
had a mentor but this mentor he was a
extra dealer my mom loved him my family
loved him and he was cleaning up his
life at the time and he ain't doing it
wrong or anything like that but it was
somebody that I was drawn to at the time
and he steered me in the right direction
and made me stay away from some of the
things that were going on in my
neighborhood and if it wasn't for him I
would say I would have been probably one
of the kids that were that's kind of
like lost in my neighborhood right now
how difficult was it for coaches to come
in and recruit you they'd have to go
into the Englewood area how nervous were
some of these college coaches I mean you
would probably have to ask them that
they were but me I grew up I lived in it
I wasn't never scared to be around like
my neighborhood but you had certain
coaches where they said they wanted me
but like my mom she didn't drive my
brother my brother's at the time they
were working in like my mom and my
brothers were gonna start working like
um like take my mom to all these college
visits because she was working too so we
felt like if you really wanted me to
play for you like you should come to
like our house and my mom I mean coach
Cal was the first coach to do so and
that's why you went to Memphis yeah
that's why I went to Memphis better
along with the team my teammates that
were there it was a older group I felt
like the only piece they were missing
was a point guard a lot of people looked
at that decision like why Memphis but
for me I always felt like I always
betted on myself even from like high
school like I went to our high school
that wasn't a basketball high school I
went to a school at the time I was a
college that was a small college and I
was able to maintain all that to the
league but I wouldn't have
got therefore one for the people in the
past how important was basketball to
your growing up it was everything it was
my own like I said I didn't I kind of
grew up different than your typical
basketball player like um even though I
lived in Chicago I was always outside I
didn't have time to oh I didn't want to
sit in front of TV all day I didn't know
what time the board games came on I
heard this player of Michael Jordan
everybody look at the time at that time
I are again I wasn't 66 I wasn't six
feet you know I mean like it our game
was the games wasn't similar so I really
didn't like look at him look up to him
like that because I was always outside
just working on my game and end up
handing off for me where like I think I
put in the right time right here the
right time the right hours to get to
where I'm at wait so you didn't really
understand the fascination with Jordan
because you didn't play the game the way
he did no no I was tending to say like
his now they know about like contracts
you know about star players you know
about just the NBA because it's a global
game when I grew up I didn't know I knew
that we were winning championships but I
wasn't able to celebrate that because I
was too young to go outside to celebrate
with the people that were running on the
streets after a championship so they win
a championship my brothers and I'm
outside and I have to sit in the house
and look from the window and see
everybody on the street celebrating so I
didn't feel that gonna you know I mean
like it was kind of different so growing
up I didn't know that you could really
get paid for basketball until like my
freshman or sophomore year in high
school and around that time that's when
my kids were like one out of high school
like and I'm like man like okay I think
I could actually may um like take care
of my family off this no and that's when
I started taking this serious my
freshman and sophomore year it came from
a comment from our brother my brother
Allen he was like in the room
and I'm honestly speaking if we wasn't
he was in the room and I'm like he was
like chopping up some drugs and like
he's totally was talking to me just
honestly and this was the first time I
heard I'm giving me a compliment about
just a good compliment about like how I
played and don't mess it up and I took
that compliment and ran with it because
um he always showed me tough love
but it's a mixed message here he's
chopping up drugs and telling you he's
proud of your game yeah I mean this is
the environment I grew up in I'm just
telling you what I grew up in ya know I
said I can only imagine what you grew up
in but you know you never felt you felt
like you were safe in that neighborhood
that now did they protect you because
you were good at basketball yeah and I
wasn't that kid I wasn't a bad kid at
all like I I was in the house at the
right time on the street light came on I
was in the house if I was on the court
late at night like my mom would walk up
to the court and wait target non-playing
and we walk back home together like
that's the type of neighborhood I grew
up and everybody knew that like I had
I'd be like goes and the crazy thing
about it like I made it like I executed
everything I wanted to do I've been
having the same type of expectations and
like Bernie's on me since I was at 6th
grade like people looked at me to get to
where I'm at right now since I was in
sixth grade and Chicago talking Derrick
Rose now with the Pistons she's written
a new book who came up with the title I
did I came up with the title with Sam
Smith mannes aion we've been cool ever
since I've been in Chicago and it was
something with me just being the
introvert like everybody lead in
different ways I feel like I leave but I
like showing my work first and you know
I mean I like actually executing and
all like talking about it I feel like
the talk of your game but everybody's
different for me I feel like I like
showing you better than tell me you got
a LeBron James story that you tell ya I
mean got a favor for you but not in the
book but I mean that's why me I tried to
get you like parts I started with the
dark I put it in I mean I put parts in
the book and I want it apart to be where
I'm being a vocal to you like you like
we're doing right now we're having the
conversation so I just wanted to come I
might get my fans and everybody that I
pay attention to me and can relate so
many different ways of interacting and
actually I'm expressing myself toughest
part of handling those that first injury
that you had yes did you know how
serious it was at the time no no I
didn't know at the time but I knew that
I could come back that was the only
thing I was worried about was coming
back but I didn't know how serious it
was at the time nor didn't and you were
written off by quite a few analysts
there right yeah I know I know but even
at the time I didn't take it personal
like it's kind of crazy I felt like I
handled it the right way like I said I
had a lot of ups and downs everything I
said in the past is what like players
are doing now is they just call it low
management yeah I think we're gonna see
more of that with these guys you know as
you get into your 30s you know that you
know you're gonna see that with you know
why is gonna do that again
Paul George will probably mean there's
no I I don't know why more guys don't do
it because I want you ready for the
postseason and if you know you're gonna
make it in the postseason
I want you healthy LeBron is gonna have
load management again this year it feels
like okay right yeah but yeah at the
time I got criticized for it because I
felt like I wasn't ready like if I would
have went out there any time all the
times that I got injured if I would have
went out there at any time before like I
really wanted to or before I want to go
on before it there's no way I woulda
guessed a year 12 I feel like but
hall-of-famer I mean that's not up to me
to decide that I know it really don't
matter in me I know that I left a print
on the game like I have a rule in the
game to like help the kids like I don't
show like that side because for the side
that like I want to show Who I am really
because I'm proud of it but I'm about
I'm about helping loving and sharing and
I felt like I I kind of helped the game
in a way where if you go out there and
you grind and you do what you're
supposed to do you get more money and I
don't think it's nothing wrong with that
there's a video of you crying when you
found out you were traded for the Bulls
to the next why why were you so
emotional that's my life Chicago
everything was there the the first thing
I thought of was my family and my son I
knew that like I cherish those moments
like Steph wouldn't have been stuff if
it's dad you know I mean like didn't
allow him to be on the court when he
shooting and all the like I love my
moments with my son when I'm actually
warming up and he's on the court on the
side when I'm crazy or he's passing me
the ball like those the moments are
cherish because I know that run up he's
gonna cherish him also and that's some a
way that we could connect on the whole
another level well hopefully it helps
you i-i've always viewed you as a
private person it was always rare I
remember when you did the GQ article
back in 2012 and you talked about
stealth mode and I I just I I always
thought it you were sort of a mystery
that we didn't really know what was
going on behind you know that exterior
there and there was a whole lot going on
yeah it was a lot but I felt like I
didn't I wasn't ready at the time at the
time I was a real like shy introvert kid
like I only reason why I'm talking to
you right now is because I matured I got
comfortable
being on countable in a space like this
and it took time at the time I wasn't
ready I wasn't mature enough to go
through everything like I am right now
but I was able to get through it with
having clearly been mindful and just
been blessed and fortunate
what was your welcome to the NBA moment
my welcome to the NBA moment yeah like
somebody dunked on you or somebody put
up no my damn ice is early man I play
terrible at somebody like there's some
leaking or Orlando yeah yeah and I
played terrible and I just remember like
down if I can't play well against these
guys like I do I got the chance that I
got a shot but the little did I know it
just grew me into like working on my
game even more and just making sure that
I was prepared to actually play an NBA
game but was there a moment where you're
on the court in you're saying I'm
guarding this guy and who would have
thought oh yeah yeah yeah all right it
was a Jay kid I think that was the first
time I ever wasn't all on the court
being a professional I was playing
against jakey I think he's clapping
Dallas at the time and it was just a
matchup you know I mean just one of the
things where it was like man I'm
actually playing against a hall-of-famer
by somebody that I looked up to so did
you talk to him it was surreal
no no I was such a nice guy yeah Jason
such a nice guy so you've said
hello mr. Kidd I'm Derek you're one of
my idols there you know I was quiet man
but he knew from the way I was playing
and competing he knew that probably that
I took the game kind of serious but Kobe
didn't talk to you did he know Kobe
didn't talk to me cope with Kobe was the
first NBA player to actually like son do
you know what's I mean like take you
under his wing know
I like this Big Brother you yeah mentor
yeah no item is different than the
mentor he's studying over he kind of he
threw his leverage on me um we were
having a commercial shoot and it was and
like Malibu somewhere and he showed up
like three hours late and I'm like I'm
like come on and like but I understood
where he was coming from like you know
how guys are
he made me pay my dues body I waited for
three hours form and he shot the
commercial of the tumors and I had to
deal with his brother so he's sending
you a message by showing up in it and
it's called leveraging you or Sonny
Sonny he is a New York turn Sonny son oh
wow I got to get hipper here Derek I'm
sorry
well I'm twice as old as you are so I
should have twice as much knowledge but
I know apparently I don't I don't have
the happy for you and I hope the book
turned out to be cathartic for you to
kind of let people in behind the curtain
a little bit there and good luck in
Detroit please tell BJ Armstrong if you
talk to BJ anymore that I said hello all
right Thank You platform for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app